and you're watching ET I need an update
on change lands change like it's coming
out June 7 in June I believe yeah in
selected theaters with mr. Macaulay
Culkin wonderful Seth Green is a
wonderful friend of mine it's his first
party he directed wrote and starred in
he did everything and he brought
basically all of his best friends to
Thailand which is you know where I'm
from and I'd never been so we spent
seven weeks in Thailand with our best
friends and made an amazing movie that
I'm excited to share with everyone I
feel like the three of you you McCole en
cess all have this in common where you
like grew up child star yeah well in
Breckin Meyer as well yeah it was really
it was really fun
you guys bonded over that or like talked
about that I mean I think that's one
thing that you know it's almost like
child actors we don't get to talk about
you just look each other in the eye and
your nod and we know I thought this is
so exciting you're returning to Disney
Channel so excited but you've literally
done over 20 Disney projects do you know
that no I didn't actually that's
actually news to me I read that this
week and I was like this is like you
were the ultimate Disney yeah here's the
thing I love Disney so much I just spent
my birthday here like not even two weeks
ago so like through and through I like
genuinely loved Disney so much and it
really does feel good to be back and
especially unveiling such an amazing
show that is so close to my heart feels
really special are you still getting
recognized out there at the park like is
that fun for you at this point
um I'm soaking for good and it's weird
it's shocking it's like real but it's
very very sweet that else that obviously
means that you know Disney has a really
loyal fans and they love the show and
the product that we put out there so I
appreciate it a lot
tell me about this new animated series
so the show is called amphibia and it is
a story of a thirty year old girl named
Ann boon Choi who gets magically
transformed into this crazy world full
of frog people and she has to find her
way back but along the way you jump on
her adventures on really understanding
yourself accepting yourself and finding
what real friends and family really are
so yeah it's been really fun cuz it's
she's actually half Thai like me and not
rally who is the creator is half Thai as
well we didn't know that when I came to
read for the project so it just sort of
happens dance and it's been really great
this show is really cute really fun I
think has a really powerful positive
message for Eileen just young
not there but for everyone how is it
playing the voice of a thirteen-year-old
it's so fun because here's the thing
it's so fun to play a thirteen-year-old
it's literally my voice I told them I'm
like I'm a one-trick pony this is all
you get and for some reason they were ok
with that so it's great I get to go to
work in my pajamas and have a good time
amazing what would you have told your 13
year old self knowing what you know now
the same thing that I would tell might
and that I still tell myself now love
yourself it's okay to make mistakes it
makes you a better person and I wish I
could tell it's in my 13 old stuff just
feel like it's gonna be okay just
remember you don't have to listen to
anyone else go with your gut instincts
because at the end of the day your
opinion is the only one that matters do
you feel like you want to be a Disney
Queen forever if I was in your position
I I would I mean I'll go with Disney
Princess tell that it's like the time of
reboots right now what Disney shows do
you think they should bring back like is
it time first a sweet life reboot I mean
I don't know I mean here's the thing I
can't I was a participating so I can't
say anything but what I would really
love is the Lizzie McGuire reboot that's
my favorite I have a secret Hilary Duff
told me that they are in talks that
would make my life that's a show that I
grew up watching so I don't know
anything you know something not at all
I'm completely kept in the dark
[Music]